marie noël legault prend une pause de
son travail pour sortir au parc avec son
garçon de trois ans avec cette nouvelle
semaine de grève qui s'ajoute à son
souper aura au total fermer ses portes
dix jours depuis le début de l'automne
pour cette pige et ceux des mères de
familles monoparentales c'est un casse
tête de trouver des solutions de
gardiennage c'est la famille ben on a la
chance d'avoir une gardienne qui skie
qui le gardait depuis tout petit donc
j'ai demandé de
peut-être cette semaine c'est toujours
le cercle habituel dead qui est mis à
contribution puis qu'on veut faire
attention aussi pour pas non plus
surchargées après les absences causés
par des mets qui collait des fermetures
de groupe en raison de l'accord vide de
nombreux parents nous disent être à bout
de souffle c'est plus qu'on se parle
mais oui je sais qu'il y en a qui sont
quand même assez à s'épuiser de
l'automne contre cornol on est un peu
chacun dans notre réalité puis que ça
devient difficile de se rassembler en
tant que parents pour faire porter pour
que notre voix porte au gouvernement
pour dire mais là ça suffit faut trouver
une solution
ce qui stagne ce sont les discussions
sur les augmentations salariales du
personnel de soutien dans les cpe on
parle notamment de postes d'entretien
d'adjoint administratif d'agents de
soutien pédagogique et de responsables
en alimentation isabelle théorêt conçoit
les menus il prépare les repas qui
changent au gré des saisons dans un cpe
de l'est de montréal si j'ai des
commandes sauvage de faire ça le matin
la commande de fruits et légumes
la commande pour les laitiers aussi
après seuil à la vaisselle de la
collation du matin qui après si je
commence la préparation du double le
gouvernement a promis une augmentation
maximale de 20,2 pour ça aux éducatrices
sur trois ans mais d'un maximum de 9 3%
sur la même période pour le personnel de
soutien j'ai étudié en techniques de
diététique 5 oct au cégep de trois ans
donc ça fait 26 ans je suis en haut de
l'échelle ont donc je paye 20 et 77
dollars dans les hôpitaux aussi à des
postes comme ça mais dans les hôpitaux
les salaires sont plus élevés pour les
personnes en alimentation au taux de 25
$
du côté des syndicats on te reconnaît
que le gouvernement a fait des
propositions salariales intéressante aux
éducatrices mais que celles prévues pour
les autres corps de métiers sont
nettement insuffisantes en faisant
valoir que ses employés contribue
beaucoup à la qualité des services dans
les gares de et nous ne voulons laisser
personne derrière notre objectif c'est
que d'ici la fin de la grève vont plus à
les voir les nous travaillons en cpe
pour aller chercher un mandat de grève
générale illimitée ils ont droit à des
moyens de pression mais je trouve ça
déplorable qu'on prenne ce départ en
otage alors qu on est encore parlé aux
comprendre que la capacité de payer elle
n'est pas illimité c'est un verre ou en
avion marie noëlle à une autre lecture
de la situation
elle estime que des demandes syndicales
sont justifiées et elle rappelle au
gouvernement que la lenteur des
pourparlers met énormément de pression
sur les épaules des parents ah c'est sûr
que ça a un prix c'est pas tous les
toutes les familles qui ont aussi un
village autour d'eux pour les aider à
des immigrants y a des il ya des gens
qui ont moins en moins et des cadeaux
qui ont au moins une chambre c'est des
grands parents qui travaillent encore
donc
oui c'est sûr qu'il ya un prix à payer
pour les parents malgré les appels à un
vote de grève générale illimitée les
discussions entre les différents
syndicats des travailleurs de cpe et le
gouvernement du québec doivent se
poursuivre tout au long de la semaine